bonjour mathieu gamma bonjour monsieur
viol dont vous êtes le référent
martinique du mouvement en marche des
manuels macron depuis le 24 octobre
dernier merci d'être avec nous au
lendemain des annonces plus que pressant
autour de la candidature de l'ancien
ministre des finances pour la
présidentielle française mais mais avant
mathieu gamme commentaires d'abord sur
le coup de théâtre de la nuit les
élections étasunienne avec la victoire
de donald trump le républicain alors ça
va vous surprendre mais moi je pense que
les démocrates avaient déjà perdu
l'élection lorsque bernie sanders n'a
pas été retenu c'est pour moi c'était le
personnage emblématique de cette
élection
les démocrates ont voté ont préféré
hillary clinton bon voilà c'est un choix
la surprise c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
match la nuit dernière en fait un donald
trump éclaté hillary clinton au grand
dam des sondages lui qui n'a aucune
expérience de gestion politique et qu'il
n'avait jamais été élu auparavant je me
garde bien de faire des comparaisons
entre trump et d'autres personnes de la
baie justement c'était la transition
pour y aller j'imagine bien ouais moi ce
que je dit juste c'est que cette
élection d' états unis il faut respecter
le suffrage universel
le peuple a décidé et puis bon pas sûr
tout ce que ça montre c'est comme avait
raison quand il disait ça sera rien de
huit rames fois aller voter donc moi ce
que j'ai envie de dire à tout le monde
sait ou faut aller voter aux élections
présidentielles françaises faudra y
aller aussi
oui la victoire de donald trump c'est un
signe pour d'autres comme certain
emmanuel macron qui n'a pas d'expérience
politique en tant que celui qui est sur
le sur le terrain qui fait campagne
alors s'il fallait faire une comparaison
entre emmanuel macron et rome je dirais
que manuel macron il a été il a été
ministre
donc il a un quand même une certaine
expérience une chose n'a pas connu
l'ambiance des campagnes des meetings il
l'a fait peut-être peut-être peut-être
mais je pense que lévis il n'y a pas de
peut-être il n'y a pas de comparaison à
faire entre les deux et puis c'est
vraiment deux situations différentes
les etats-unis sont dans un état de
délabrement politique avancée avec cette
guerre des tranchées ce climat
républicains démocrates qui qui qui est
insolvable chez eux consacrent aux 10
dans le projet vite avortée de
martinique est gagnante avec francette
rosa mans c'était lors des élections
pour la collectivité territoriale de
martinique en décembre dernier
aujourd'hui vous êtes avec monsieur
macron pourquoi comment vas-tu gamin ben
parce qu'en fait je me retrouve
je retrouve un peu de l'esprit
marcinelle gagnante dans le march
martini gagnante c'était un parti qui se
voulait trans partisan au dessus du
clivage gauche droite français c'est un
parti qui sait qu'ils avaient une
approche un peu spiritualiste on parlait
d'un d'altérité l'autre c'est moi et je
suis l'autre on parlait de bienveillance
aussi dans le discours politique de
civiliser un peu les échanges politiques
et le discours politique et donc je me
retrouve totalement dans ce que fait
manuel macro et donc causer
naturellement que lorsque j'ai été
sollicité j'ai dit oui vous avez été et
comme choisi de soutenir un homme qui
est sur le point de 1ère d celui qu'il a
fait émerger
ça ne vous gêne pas ça non parce que je
ne suis pas d'accord avec votre vision
des choses
mais je vais vous dire que l'histoire
politique française est émaillé de ce
genre de schéma
nicolas sarkozy l'a fait avec jacques
chirac en choisissant balladur à gauche
on pourrait prendre les mêmes exemples
la loyauté c'est d'abord la loyauté à
soi même et à ses idées
emmanuel macron et un désaccord
politique avec la ligne gouvernementale
hollande valls il l'a dit il l'a répété
ils se sont accrochés sur sur
l'explication à apporter aux attentats
en france
emmanuel macron disaient les terroristes
sont des françaises sont des jeunes de
nos sites et donc on a on doit se poser
la question où est ce que la république
a échoué pour que ça arrive
emmanuel macron lui le banquier homme
d'affaires 1
le banquier d'affaires jamais est en
campagne ne sais pas ce que c'est que
très tôt de campagne et qui passe pour
un ultra libéralisme et qui fait ce que
les patrons et les milieux d'affaires
veulent bien c'est comme ça qu'il faut
le voir je ne pense pas je ne pense pas
je pense que le la proche des manuels
macron n'est pas lié à son métier de
banquier d'affaires c'est comme si moi
on disait mais vous vous êtes huissier
de justice mathieu gamma donc vous avez
une vision très rigide de la société
c'est pas vrai c'est sait on fait des
ont fait les métiers qui nous sont
proposés et on répond à des opportunités
il se trouve que emmanuel macron un
discours très social on l'oubli où on ne
l'entend pas assez et donc aussi se
déplacer sur le terrain en tant que
ministre il semblait quand même avoir un
sacré décalage entre ce qu'il voulait
dire ce qu'il voulait faire et puis la
réalité des petites personnes sur le
terrain messieurs veulent qu'on vous
connaissez
l'impact des réseaux sociaux quand on
prend 10 10 10 secondes d'une
intervention ou d'un accrochage lui il
va où lui au moins il va au contact des
gens quand ils l'histoire du t-shirt ou
d'autres histoires avec les employés
gars d'ici expliqué dessus à de
nombreuses reprises et très longuement
dans l'interview qu'il a donnée à
mediapart et il faut pas il faut pas
déformer ni sortir les propos de leur
contexte je pense qu'au bout notre
travail ici en martinique pour en mars
et de faire entendre le discours d'
emmanuel macron et il ya beaucoup de
gens seront surpris du de la défense qui
l'a de l'égalité sociale surtout ne pas
montrer qu'il fait partie d'une
etablishment on a vu ce que ça peut
donner ne serait-ce que l'année dernière
aux états unis
vous savez la force d'un homme politique
c'est de parler à toutes les catégories
de la population
moi je pense qu'il en est capable c'est
un homme jeune
il se nomme qui saura parler un peuple
qui voit le chômage à des taux trop
élevé des impôts qui augmentent qui est
qu'ils subissent des hausses
vertigineuses en dépit des déclarations
des uns et des autres c'est le seul
homme politique à avoir organisé une
marche s'être penché sur ce que vivent
au quotidien les français
donc oui je penserai maybach zeppelin
programme ça à ils étaient pas il n'est
pas question de que la marche soit un
programme la marche a servi à recueillir
l'avis des français et c'est bien ça le
plus important parce que construire un
programme dans son bureau élyséen
ministériel ou autres en disant voilà
moi je suis une arc et je sais c'est une
erreur fondamentale est donc là l'un ce
qu'on lui reproche maintenant c'est de
pas avoir de programme mais il est en
train de préparer avec nous un contrat
de transformation la société française
notre travail c'est de recueillir
justement les propositions des uns et
des autres dans la dans la société
civile pour qu'ils puissent faire des
propositions la candidature d'emmanuel
macron s'ajouter à gauche à celle de
jean luc mélenchon de yannick jadot
d'europe écologie les verts à celui qui
sortira de la primaire socialiste bref
c'était une vraie machine à perdre tout
ça car trop divisés déjà dans cette
partie de la famille politique française
je pense qu'au contraire ça marque une
vitalité démocratique
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de politiques
sont intéressés par cette élection
d'ailleurs moi je trouve ça assez
louable que manuellement qu'on prenne le
temps de la réflexion avant d'aller à
cette élection s'est engag en
s'engageant pour lui d'ailleurs pour sa
famille ses engagements à tous points de
vue et donc qu'il faut respecter le
temps qu'il a demandée pour y réfléchir
et sa lancée j'espère personnellement
qu'il ira quitté de droite ou de gauche
emmanuel macron il a dit lui-même c'est
un homme de gauche
mais cela est ans c'est justement c'est
moi je suis assez heureux qu'il ait dit
d'ailleurs qu'il ai dit voilà moi je
suis de gauche je ne suis pas du parti
socialiste mais je suis de gauche je
suis de gauche mais je veux rassembler
c'est pas parce que je suis de gauche
que je ne travaille qu'avec des gens de
gauche on sort de la logique des
boutiques doc un homme de gauche avec le
plan de route pour la martinique une
feuille de route
alors j'y vois là dedans justement vous
avez vu passer les uns et les autres de
droite comme de gauche ou du centre qui
viennent avec des idées en disant voilà
nous voilà ce qu'on veut pour les
antilles on veut faire ça on veut faire
ça
à quel moment ces chalands demandé aux
antilles est ce qu'ils voulaient à quel
moment tous parlent de concertation tous
disent on a rencontré on a échangé on a
discuté on a eu un bon ouais ben non non
et non parce que si ça avait été le cas
moi je suis un citoyen engagé donc si ça
avait été le câblage et me serais
intéressé aux j'aurais été rencontré
l'un de ceux là et ça et moi j'en ai
jamais entendu parler ou alors comment
vous allez vous y prendre vous mathieu
gamma pour faire remonter et ses
aspirations martiniquaise est ce que
d'ailleurs odeo dessus de vous il y aura
une sorte de référent outre mer comme on
dit non on a des référents territoriaux
il y en a un en guadeloupe en guyane à
la réunion et dans sur tous les
territoires
un mois mon job c'est d'un d'animer les
comités locaux qui ont été créées de
fédérer les adhérents qui sont d'en
avoir plus d'organiser des réunions qui
nous avait déjà du monde avec 12 ans
avait été désigné le 24 octobre dernier
mais ça fait pas longtemps
exactement d'eau consommées ont acquis
avec vous les abris zik ya pas de
politique il ya des gens de la société
civile
on est mais vous savez rien dire ça la
société civile savez je vais vous
expliquer rapidement il y aura des gens
il y aura des politiques pour la simple
et bonne raison que si emmanuel macron
décide d'aller à l'élection
présidentielle il va lui falloir sa
signature et donc je ne doute pas que
ces équipes feront le travail pour
rencontrer commencé ce travail en
martinique et de séduction de
rapprochement pour essayer d'obtenir
quelques signatures martiniquaise ce
n'est pas ma tâche moi je ne suis pas
chargé de cela ça c'est imminent mans
politique
et je pense qu'il a autour de lui un
cabinet politique qui ce qui rencontrera
que ce soit nos députés nos sénateurs ou
des membres de la ctm pour pour impulser
un mouvement dans le microcosme
politique
moi je suis chargé au contraire de la
société civile et de faire en sorte que
des gens qui sont des déçus de leur
engagement à gauche ou à droite et qui
sont d'accord avec cet acquis par
exemple vous voulez des noms c'est un
beau ne va pas nous sommes entre nous
non non non mais je vous donnerai pas
non surtout des milieux d'affaires nous
ferons connaître le discours ben non pas
du tout pas du tout parce qu'en fait
quand on écoute le discours d' emmanuel
macron il dit une chose il dit il faut
sortir du clivage droite gauche il ya
bien le vrai clivage il est entre
réformistes et conservateurs
et si on veut que la france change et
donc par ricochet nous aussi les
antilles et martiniquais guadeloupéens
guyanais on est une autre approche
il faut sortir de cette logique de
boutiques mais surtout il faut poser
être d'accord sur un socle idéologique
c'est là la faillite des grands partis
jusqu'à maintenant autres seconds vins
de mâcon vivre en martinique ans
j'espère qu'il sera là avant la fin de
l'année et j'espère que j'espère qu'il
tiendra un discours assez innovant sûr
sur les antilles mission la vision des
anciens merci d'avoir été avec nos
mathieu gars m'en rappelle que vous êtes
le référent martinique du mouvement en
marche crié par emmanuel macron bonne
journée